All right. Welcome. It's two minutes after, so I guess we'll get started.
I've heard from the panelists that they've got some really compelling
presentations for you, and they might go over a little bit.
So I want to just
go ahead and get us started so that we'll have plenty of time to
hear from each of them.
So, my name is Kim Rhoads. I'm a professor of surgery
at VCU, and I am the associate director for
Community Outreach and Engagement at Massey Comprehensive Cancer Center.
I have no relevant financial relationships to disclose.
And I just wanted to take a little temperature of who's in the room.
Just so I have a sense of how much you know about community outreach and
engagement. So are there any COE leaders, any people
who lead a COE in the room
right now? Okay, I see one at least. Okay.
Any staff from COE?
Good. Community health educators?
Okay.
Yeah, great. A couple up in front. And then any early stage
investigators?
Awesome. Love the representation. COE, that's why you're here.
Any collaborators? So investigators who have worked with their local
community outreach and engagement office to get-- Oh, look, we've got one of
everything so far. Okay, any community partners,
patient advocates, or survivors in the room?
Okay, love COE. Okay, anybody in this
none of the above category of no idea what COE is? No idea.
Big hands for no idea. Big hands, come on.
Okay, you have some idea. Little baby hand.
All right, great. So I'm going to give a little bit of a background about COE,
but I like to always just check who's in the room.
And I think hopefully, since it's an intimate crowd, that you will
all speak up and interact with us from the perspectives that you're
bringing,
because as COE leaders, we all really appreciate that
representation.
So for those of you who are less familiar with COE, I just want to make
the very important point that in order to be a comprehensive
cancer center as designated by the National Cancer Institute, you
actually have to have a COE component and
activities in your cancer center, and our cancer centers all
occupy a really unique role. The expectation is that we will
engage the people who are living in those defined catchment areas
to help define and direct the research that we do at the center.
The idea is that your research at the center has direct implications for the
people living in the catchment area around you.
So I'm just going to briefly talk about the evolution of community outreach and
engagement, because there are a lot of people who were doing this work
before it got the name or title
of COE.
And the war on cancer in this country really started in the early '70s.
And so we're going to fast forward
40 years
and come up to 2012 when the CCSG,
which is the Cancer Center Support Grant, which is the thing that makes your
comprehensive cancer center comprehensive,
said that there is a requirement to do, quote, "something in the community."
And that's not a direct quote, but I remember when I had my first job leading
COE, it was aimed to do something in the community.
It didn't say what.
In 2016, and then again in 2019, when they released
the FOA or the call for proposals, they formalized
COE and said that it is required to actually
touch every corner of your cancer center.
So that includes basic, translational, and clinical research,
as well as cancer control, which was where it was already born.
People who were interested in screening and early detection, they were already out
in the community. They knew that the work needed to touch the community.
But it's the rest of the cancer center that was maybe not quite aware of
what COE was doing or supposed to do.
In 2025, you all may recall that things in the country started to change in
terms of what we do with community, how we name the
communities that we're working with, and what our actual goals
are. So you saw that manifested in the
CCSG in that the plan to enhance diversity,
or what we sometimes called shorthand DEI, was
completely eliminated as a requirement from the
Cancer Center Support Grant.
When that happened, because some people can't tell a difference
between diversifying your leadership and actually doing the
work that moves the research in the cancer
center to reflect the needs of the community, they couldn't tell a difference
between DEI and COE. So there started to be these conversations about maybe COE
should go away also.
And now here we are in 2026, waiting for the next FOA to
tell us what exactly it is that we are expected to do.
Has not come out yet. I think we're expecting it within the next several
months.
So for now, what NCI expects of COE is to
characterize the burden of cancer
and disparities in the center's catchment area and to socialize that
information to the investigators inside the catchment area or inside
the cancer center, so that they start to target their work toward the catchment
area. The second thing is that we're supposed to engage with community partners,
do cancer education, increase awareness and knowledge, as well as
uptake of evidence-based interventions that reduce risk, help people get
screened, or help them seek care.
We're also expected to implement evidence-based interventions to increase
the screening and early detection in the catchment area, and also to
address potentially social barriers to getting that care.
And then finally, and this is the challenging part, is to catalyze,
as I said, community-engaged and community-based participatory research
across all of the programs in your
cancer center,
and then also promote inclusion in cancer clinical
trials.So now I'm just briefly going
to outline some of the challenges that COE is currently
facing. Some of them are sort of historical, but moving
into the now.
The first is that before things started to change in
January of 2025, we already were having some issues
with
what some folks in a group called the Alliance for the Science of Community
Outreach and Engagement wrote in "The Cancer Letter" about threats
to COE, and really making it hard for us to achieve
any of the work that we said that we were going to set out to do, especially as
regards disparities.
And this, I just want to point out here that what was happening then, and I think
it's hard to remember because things have become so much more draconian,
but we were having states that were ready to ban books,
sort of erase histories and discussions of
LGBTQ community, people of color, not talking about slavery.
And frankly, around this time
when this article was published, the NAACP had issued a
travel advisory for Black people and people, sexual
and gender minorities,
in the state of Florida. So things were already bubbling
before January 2025, and then you all remember what
happened. It was almost overnight.
People started getting notices of termination for their grants, because they had
the verboten or forbidden words in them.
They focused on minoritized groups or talked about
marginalization, could not mention anything related to DEI,
and the whole focus, very explicitly, was to eliminate efforts to get
to health equity.
And some of you may have seen the article in "Stat News" where
there was a leaked NIH memo that said, "Disparities are still within
the scope and interest of this administration.
However, poverty, employment, and immigration status should not be
studied as part of the disparities work." I'm hopeful that that
leaked memo will make them say, "No, no, we weren't going to do
that after all."
We'll see when the FOA comes out.
So the second challenge of COE is that maybe it
has too much influence. So the COE descriptor, the way it's
graded or scored, strongly influences the overall cancer
center support grant score. And you see I put a dollar sign in score, because your
score on your cancer center overall determines, to some extent, how much
money you're going to get in that grant.
So this study from 2024, I think it
was actually, I heard it in 2023 presented,
looked at 48 of 62 NCI designated and comprehensive
cancer centers and asked them all questions about how they run their COE.
And what they found was that they had 77% of the centers
responded, and what they showed, and what's really important, is a strong
correlation, and follow this red line here.
These are comprehensive cancer centers, whereas this flat
line is non-comprehensive or just designated or clinical
cancer centers. And what you can see is that the COE merit descriptor or
the COE score, which is along the X-axis here,
directly correlated with the center's overall score,
and these scores are going up. And for those of you who are not familiar with the
NIH scoring system, the higher your score, the worse off
you are. So what this correlation showed us is that it's almost
like COE, I think people felt a bit like it was the tail
wagging the dog.
So of course, the alliance had to write another article in
"The Cancer Letter," just making the point that we need to move from
the mandate that NCI has given us, which says you have to do
COE work, to thinking about it as a mission
instead. Because that mandate and the correlation
that I just showed you between what COE gets in terms of a score and what the
center gets in terms of a score, was actually giving some
of the cancer center directors heartburn.
And
what I want to point out about that is what that means then is some center
directors would want COE to maybe involute, go away,
be less important, have less of an impact
on the score because it would have less impact on the finances.
So that there's actually an incentive there, or I should say a disincentive
to support COE, yet COE persists. Okay,
last challenge that I'm going to point out is that for those of you who have
worked either in COE or with your COE leaders, you know that what we're
asked to do is everything,
right? We have to know the
inside of the cancer center, what research is going on across all types
of research, and then we have to know what's going on outside the cancer center
with the community, and then we have to understand what's happening with the health
systems that are surrounding our cancer centers.
So in some ways, I would argue you have to know more than the cancer center
director.
Don't tell him I said that. Okay. So,
there's confusion, as I said before.
COE is not the plan to enhance diversity. It's not about DEI.
It is for every population.
It doesn't matter race, ethnicity, sexual orientation.
COE is for everybody in your catchment area.
We also face concerns about who are reviewing COE
component when you go up for your comprehensive status.
Often, it's not a COE leader. Often, it's not someone who even
understands what COE is supposed to accomplish.
So it's difficult to get a good review that is robust and gives you
guidance. If you're going to get a bad score, what can we do better?
Sometimes you get no guidance, because who's reviewing? They may not know.
I won't even talk about the site visit.
For those of you who've been through a site visit, I don't want to re-traumatize
you, so I'm going to skip that.
And then the question about metrics. What is impact?
And I like to say, what is impact versus impact factors?
Have you made something better for your community or have you published a paper?
Which one is actually going to make a palpable difference?
SoThese are the things that make COE hard.
So in that article that I mentioned before, the Rebecca article,
they asked COE leaders from across the country: What are you
actually doing? What are your roles and responsibilities?
And you can see, there's determining what the catchment area is and what's
happening in the catchment area. There's cancer disparities, there's global health.
There's community advisory board leadership, education, and training.
So instead of the question, what is COE expected to do, I would argue we should be
asking, what is COE not expected to do?
It's literally everything.
So the challenges persist, and when you mix all of this together, you get a little
bit of
a disaster. You get really hard work that
has to be done sort of dancing between the pylons
of limits that are given to us by HHS and the
expectations of everybody in the cancer center.
So what we've got is you can do disparities work, but you can't name the
populations that you're worried about, right?
You can't analyze whether or not social determinants or social drivers are
actually having an impact, and especially poverty.
We know that those correlations are going to be there.
And then you have these targeted grant terminations that didn't
really hit cancer centers, but they hit a lot of health equity
work. So then you're losing your partners because you've lost momentum, because
you've lost your support.
Nonetheless, through all of this, we still have a million expectations of
COE, and we still have this continued influence of the merit
descriptor on the overall cancer center score.
So the purpose of the panel today is to check in with three COE leaders
from across the country,
and we're going to listen to what they're doing to not only navigate the
challenges but also innovate as they're moving forward, implement novel
approaches to meet that high bar of making sure COE touches every corner
of the cancer center, and then making plans for how to sustain the work.
So I'm going to go ahead and introduce our three speakers, and they're going to
come up in sequence. And then we'll have time for questions at the
end. If you have a burning question, we want to hear it anyway, so pop in.
So first you're going to hear from Dr.
Lourdes Vizconde-Gabinati, who is, I just am going to admit
here publicly, is my idol in COE. I'm serious.
Because she really moved a population level outcome, and if she doesn't talk about
it, you should ask her about it. Incredible.
She's a distinguished professor of population and public health sciences.
She's the associate director for COE at USC
Norris Comprehensive
Cancer Center, and Senior Associate Dean of Community Engagement
at the Keck School of Medicine.
Because once they find a COE leader, then you have to do all
this community engagement all through the campus.
And with that, I'll turn the mic over to Lourdes.
Wow, so I will pay you later. Thank you.
Good afternoon, everybody. Thank you so much for being here.
I know that many of you have been here since Friday, so this
is getting towards the tail end, so we really appreciate you being here
today. So I'm going to talk a little bit about
how we're navigating this climate and really using
storytelling to work on some of the things that
will remain unmentioned in terms of nomenclature that we can no
longer use, but that we're still working towards,
because disparities in our community continue to exist,
even though
some of the areas that we can cover may not
necessarily be exactly the same.
So I'm part of the Keck School of Medicine.
I receive research support from Genentech, the National Cancer
Institute, and NIMHHD. I'm also the
chair of the board of directors of the National Alliance for Hispanic Health, which
works with 200 community-based organizations around the country
and really oversees the health of 15 million Hispanics.
So, the community outreach and engagement at our
cancer center navigates change and maintains
impact by accomplishing NCI mandates.
And those mandates include monitoring and supporting reductions in the cancer
burden. And what we have used is really this word of the cancer
burden to really help work with our populations in different
ways, promote greater research, work with clinics to
increase cancer screening, ensure that all populations benefit from
the cancer center research in what we're now calling our commitment areas.
So we've been getting some lax in terms of not having to call them catchment
areas anymore, and beyond that. And also enhance
inclusion in clinical trials and actively collaborate with basic
scientists, ensuring that bidirectionality, and that has been one of
my passions. How do we work with the basic scientists?
How do we get them engaged, and how do we get our communities engaged with
them in truly bidirectional ways?
So, to navigate change, monitor, and maintain impact,
we have been telling stories recently.
And some of those stories we have been telling through different ways.
GIS mapping is one of them, and I'll show you some examples of
that. We're now working with artificial intelligence and AI
to really introduce elements that will facilitate the work that we're
doing, and then we rely a lot on edutainment or
storytelling using videos, reels, and social media.
And I'm going to present specific examples from our work in cervical and
colorectal cancer.
So the GIS mapping of the cancer burden in our commitment
area has been really important to be able to focus on those
areas that have the greatest disparities.
So we work with our population core and our SEERS Registry data.
We utilize data from LA County Open Data Sources, GeoHub,
from the California Health Maps, and the State Cancer ProfilesTo help produce
mapping over time that's going to tell our story.
So we don't just say, "Oh,
here's the incidents, and that's what we're working on," but we really tell the
story over time of how we have made a
difference in reducing the cancer burden.
So for example, I will show you here, this is how we tell the
story of cervical cancer in our commitment area.
So in 2005, we started several campaigns, including our
Tamale Lesson and also our Stampo campaign,
which really targeted cervical cancer screening.
And I want to focus on the maps on the right, because you will
see how we, with our community partners, have made
a difference in reducing the incidence of cervical
cancer in our catchment area. So you see this is
2015, and then this is 2020.
If you turn to the left of the slide, you have the 2025
map. So between 2020 and 2025, what happened?
The pandemic. And so we saw some
reduced
screening because everybody was in that.
And then with new policies, including policies related to
vaccinations, we've seen some setbacks in this area.
And so even though we have made incredible strides
overall, we have now a little bit more work to do and
more catch-up to do. The same is here in terms of navigating
change in our GIS mapping over time in colorectal
cancer. And precisely in our catchment area, this is the kind of
map that you tend to see mostly, but I encourage you to try to use
GIS mapping so you can produce these other kinds of mapping that
really tell the story. All of these are our community partners in there, and the
little star is who we are. So you can really tell the story of what you've
done and how you've helped to reduce that cancer burden.
So now we're working on colorectal cancer because we're seeing higher rates
under the age of 50, plus disparities in screening, especially in
Hispanic populations, which is a very large proportion of the
population in Los Angeles, especially among those Hispanics with
limited English proficiency.
So that's one way that we have utilized to tell our
story. Another way is really capitalizing on edutainment.
Edutainment is a combination of education and entertainment
in order to harness the power of storytelling to advance
precision in communication. This is another code word, precision
communication, advancing precision communication.
If you're going to be precise about a population, and you have to be
able to work with that population, then you need to produce evidence
that you are really making a difference.
One of the things that we found is that nearly 90% of Americans
struggle to understand complex health information delivered through
traditional methods. Those of you who work in cancer, imagine if that is
also loaded with the feelings and the fears that come from a
diagnosis of cancer. So it's not just getting a
diagnosis, it is a cancer diagnosis, ladies and gentlemen.
And we all know, because either we have felt it or loved ones have felt it,
how that really gets to you. And so that moment,
you can't hear anything else, right?
It's like all of a sudden, you know that you have a death sentence in
your head, is what you think about.
So
imagine that in the middle of struggling to understand all the
information that's being landed to you.
Storytelling has shown us that it cuts through this complexity.
And now what we're finding is that we can pair storytelling with AI and
social media to really accelerate the engagement of our
participants and to increase participation in clinical trials
and also engagement in a lot of the work that we do.
So we can transform complex data into relatable
narratives. We can improve patient and population outcomes.
We can entertain while engaging individuals.
We foster patient and community advocacy, and we encourage
participants to engage in research on cancer.
So this started back, and I want to recognize Elena
Taylor, who's here, who worked with me at the very origins of Tamale Lesson.
And some of you who know my long-term
work in this area, this is our Tamale Lesson, which was the origin of some
of the storytelling. And I'm not going to play the whole thing, but I'll play you
just a couple of seconds of it. And if you want to see the whole thing, you go to
Tamale Lesson USC,
so that you can not get tamale lessons per se, but you know how to make tamales,
but you actually see this video.
And this resulted
in 13 different journal articles.
And I worked on this with the School of Communication, Dr.
Sheila Murphy, and with the Annenberg School of Communication and Journalism,
and with the cinema school, with Jeremy Kagan and Dole Mayer.
So here's a little bit about Tamale Lesson, which was our first.
Have you ever had a Pap test?
No. I told you, I'm a virgin.
Okay. It's true. You mainly get HPV from sex.
What?
So what? You're 21, and you should get yourself checked out anyway.
Checked out for what?
A Pap test.
So I won't go farther into it because some of you have already seen this,
but what happens is that we don't always have to be dramatic
about everything that's happening.
So we actually use humor, and we have a chicken, which we show
how to do a Pap test on a chicken. And then people can
see how the Pap test is actually done.
And then they discuss this during the film, and they
learn. And the results of that
show that 45% increase in the number of
people who actually got an appointment or were
already screened in the end of six months.
So we managed to reduce an entire population disparity
just using this interventionSo now with all of that knowledge
learned, we're blending AI with authentic participant storytelling
to deliver culturally tailored messages in language and
directly to high-risk populations.
We also train and deploy trusted messengers and
deliver our medium through social media, videos, short reels,
podcasts, and other communication channels.
So we've developed this model or framework, which is the artificial intelligence
and community translation framework, which shows how we're
developing AI-assisted blueprints, pre-production
validation, AI-generated storyboards, and I'm going to show you
some of that, how we pilot our contact, produce materials and
derivatives that use mobile devices and social media, train and
deploy our community workers, and then monitor and evaluate change.
So what is this AI-assisted blueprint outline?
We utilize generative AI to draft simplified
low health literacy scripts, converting complex clinical
information into simplified, accurate, and
easy-to-understand narratives.
So we do pre-production validation through focus groups.
So for example, to the right, so I put a report into
one of those AI writing checkers. Apparently, it's currently written at the
47th-grade reading level.
Wow.
So we tend to sometimes not
or forget that the patients and those that we're working
directly with don't have the same level of education
necessarily or of information that we do.
So we ran focus groups to see what they're thinking.
We have AI-generated storyboard visualization.
So now all of this is facilitated. This used to take weeks,
months.
Yeah.
Now you do it in just hours. And so here is an entire
storyboard, which is based on focus groups that were held
first, and then we developed the scripts, and we have the entire
storyboard that is presented before us.
So these are AI-generated images.
And I'm going to play...
And then we get feedback. So for example, they didn't want to see cartoons.
They wanted to see more people. And I'm going to show you some of our
more primitive that we're still working on to perfect.
But this was one of our earlier ones.
Meet Auntie Rose and her dear friend, Ms. Clara.
Auntie Rose loves cooking and sharing her wisdom, and today she has
something important to talk about with Ms. Clara.
"Clara, now that you've turned 45, I want to share
something very important with you."
"Oh,
what is it, Auntie Rose?"
"Just like I care for my garden, I want to make sure you take care
of your health."
So I'm going to stop there because of the sake of time.
But you could see this was one of our earlier ones, and I wanted to
show you that because I'm going to show you a later one of how we have evolved
through the entire process. But I want to recognize Bianca
Rosales, who is here, and Bianca, raise your hand, who has helped us
tremendously in helping to produce some of that.
And she created Auntie Rose based on AI,
and so it's getting the young people in who know what
they're doing with this AI is really important.
But we cannot move forward unless we really validate
this with our patients and our communities.
So the community validation piece is really essential.
This was just this
month of April, where we had a CAB and participant meeting through our
COPEC, which is funded by our National Cancer Institute,
through our PECGS network, and I'd like to recognize Leah Mechanic,
who is here from NCI. Raise your hand, Leah.
Who provides us with the funding for some of this.
So we just held this to get really information back from our
communities and our patients themselves about
what they're seeing, how they're receiving this, whether it's conveying the right
kind of messages. One of the things that we have worked
on is a film that is produced, which is to be used at
the time of return of results.
Wow.
Imagine you're getting a genetic result.
This is very confusing time for you.
But this is combined with real people, our genetic counselors,
that are working directly with you, present this video to you,
and are working there with you presenting your results.
So one of the things that we found that they told us was that they wanted to
use experts to relieve that anxiety over the clinical procedures
such as screening for colorectal cancer.
But they didn't want to hear all the facts and all of that.
They wanted someone to talk to them like they would.
If they could see this at home as well, or use and use real
patients to tell their stories. So this is Sergio.
Good morning. I'm Sergio Juarez. One day, I felt a
terrible pain on my left side. I didn't sleep at all that night,
couldn't take the pain anymore. I went to the general hospital, and
after some tests, they told me, "You have cancer, and we
need to operate." I felt bad.
They did the surgery. In that moment, my life took a
360-degree turn. We don't-
So, for that, and it's an eight-minute film, so I'm not going to
show it here, but I can certainly send it to you.
And we portray three different patients.
We portray Sergio, who's a beekeeper.
We portray Doña Ceci, who's the older lady here, and her family,
and what they're all going through.
And we portray another one
of our patients as well, who literally participated with us and an
entire film crew from the School of Cinema to
do that. And I want to recognize in particular Lena Taylor, who's here, who
has helped us to produce this film as well, and everybody
else in our team that has been really instrumental in doing
thatSo I do want to tell you something, that you also have to
make sure that people identify, are transported, and really understand
what the messaging is. Because the story of Serhi the beekeeper was
so interesting that they did not hear anything that we were
saying related to the information.
They just wanted the story of the beekeeper.
So we had to take some of the beekeeping science stuff out
so that we could get our message in.
So, it's not just go make a video. You got to really think through this.
But what are we doing? We are taking all of this that we've done, and we're
generating, through AI, new materials.
We're working on fotonovelas, we're working on websites, we're
working on short videos, and on derivatives for social media
using AI technology. It used to take us a year to produce a
fotonovela. I think we did it, Sam, in what?
A few days.
A few days. So Sam here, she is with other members of our team
on the Genentech grant, Bianca and Rosa, and they helped to
produce some of these products. Also, Sam has been
working on our Mi Salud, which is a National Cancer
Institute-funded multicultural, multilingual campaign.
And this campaign is patterned after our previous Es Tiempo
campaign, which used, in addition to all the social media,
we used outdoor signage to remind people to go
in for cervical cancer screening.
So in Los Angeles, we have the blooming of the beautiful jacaranda tree.
And every time it blooms, and we've been doing this for a few years, people are
reminded to go in and get their screening or get their HPV
vaccine.
Right.
And so that's part of what we're doing.
And now we've created a YouTube channel where we're putting all of our
different materials as well. And here's our team in front of the
billboards. And so in addition to that, we're producing
different educational videos. And you have to be really thoughtful in this
process because even the way that you film
is really important. If you're going to use it on a
smartphone, you have to have the
framing, whether it's one way or the other.
And so,
these are really things that we need to think about because literally all of
us are on some kind of social media, or we're all on
our phones all the time. And so let's capitalize and utilize that
as such. We're also producing digital toolkits now, including
promotores and community health workers manuals, social media clips,
YouTube channels, WhatsApp. So we communicate with our promotores de
salud through WhatsApp, also Instagram and Facebook, Google Search Ads,
so that we're the first ones that come up.
Then we work with our churches, our faith-based partnerships, our community health
workers, and our clinic partners.
We train and deploy our community health workers out into the community.
We have a team for one of our programs, our CoGiMS, has
over 40 community workers. Bianca, is that 40 or 49
now?
Forty-five community health workers that are deployed through our CoGiMS program.
And this to the right is our community outreach
in the Koreatown area of Los Angeles.
As you know, LA is incredibly diverse, so we have to produce
things in different languages. We work with community
faith-based events. For example, the first one is a gospel
choir. This is through a grant with Stand Up To Cancer,
with Dr. L. Curry and Dr. Shenita Hughes Halbert.
And we worked with multiple churches and literally created these
concert opportunities where we brought all of our materials as
well and had some of that. And I want to recognize our
Care2, both Carolina and Eduardo are here from
Care2, and others might be here, too, as we also
produce all the outreach that we're doing out in the various
communities. So what are we doing next?
So now we're planning a new program. It's called ConnectHome.
It's a bi-directional home-to-clinic, back-to-home
colorectal cancer outreach and navigation screening program working with
the clinics in Los Angeles. These are low-income,
safety net clinics to train, deploy, and connect
community health workers with clinic patients who are at risk for
CRC to ensure follow-up, community navigation
from home to clinic, follow-up on kits that are mailed
to their home, ensure that the kits are mailed back, and
ensure that the clinic is informing the patients back
until they reach a diagnostic resolution.
So our community workers are actively
engaged in really reaching our populations now
directly in their homes. Okay, so why are we going into the homes?
I think Dr.
Kim Rhoads mentioned some of the challenges that we face.
We can't even get people to come in to get free food, and so
we need to take it to their homes. So ConnectHome is a response, in
part, to the political climate that we live in in order to ensure that
our patients get served where they are at.
And so we monitor and evaluate these changes through digital
engagement evaluation, our program evaluation,
promotores training, and behavioral intentions to either assess
intent to complete their screening or intent to adopt healthy behaviors,
whether that's diet or physical activity.
We're thus leveraging AI for initial scripting and
storyboarding, testing AI-generated scripts and visuals with focus
populations, and ensuring the final educational material
content is directly aligned with that community needs,
whatever that population is. And producing AI blueprints that can be
utilized to successfully guide the spin-up of additional
materials. So this approach has really helped us transform
communication into action. It has amplified the
patients' voices, and it has optimally conveyed
cancer information.Our next steps is to produce high impact,
culturally tailored materials to deliver these clear
cancer education messaging across the entire digital
divide, from online platforms to low literacy
and print accessible formats based on the populations that we're
addressing, engaging community clinics as our partners
in screening, utilizing some of these products produced, and
continuing to train and engage patient advocates and their
families to be part of the solution.
So that's pretty much it for me, and I will
give you some questions for me.
Now you can see why
I said what I said.
All right, so next up, we're going to hear from Dr.
Pamela Hull, who's Professor of Behavioral Science,
and Associate Director of Population Science and
Community Impact at the University of Kentucky Markey Cancer Center.
She's going to talk to us about strategies for facilitating community involvement
in cancer research to enhance community impact.
Welcome.
Well, I really don't want to follow up after Lourdes.
That was so amazing. I'm just like, "Okay, am I going to be boring
now?"
So very impressive work. I always love-- We have the
COE leaders and teams and staff. We have such a great
community. We love learning from each other and just hearing all the exciting
things that's going on in all the different communities.
So anyway, so I'm going to be talking
about one of the four things that Kim laid out, of the four
kind of things we do want. This is the
kind of facilitating involvement of community organizations,
community members, community partners in research, not as research
participants, but as partners and as
informing research and being part of research.
And, disclosures, I just want to say I'm speaking of my own personal
opinions. These are not the views of University of Kentucky.
I have to say that.
To give you a little context of our work, in Kentucky, our catchment
area, love that new term, commitment area, our area that we serve is the
entire state,
4.5 million people. So we have, not a huge
number of people, but it's a large state, so our kind of bigger
challenge is more geographic scope of getting all across the
state.
And we have a lot of challenges in our state in terms of
socioeconomic challenges. We have a large rural
population, and you may be aware that the eastern half of our state
is part of Appalachia. It's specifically the central Appalachian
or sort of sub-region of Appalachia, which has the lowest socioeconomic
indicators and,
basically almost all of the counties in Appalachian Kentucky are
persistent poverty counties.
And overall, our state has kind of lower education and higher
poverty levels. A bright spot is we have
Medicaid expansion, so that's a
very grateful resource that we have.
So we do have lower uninsured rate than the US.
So I'm going to just talk about two things
that we're doing. There's lots and lots of stuff that we do, but I'm just going to
talk specifically about two,
to kind of help meet the needs of our state.
So one is our Markey Cancer Network.
It's kind of a unique network. It's one of the reasons why I came to Kentucky,
because it's pretty amazing.
So as you may or may not know, most patients
don't come to NCI-designated cancer centers for their cancer treatment
or even university academics medical centers.
Eighty-five percent or so of cancer patients are treated
everywhere else, in community hospitals all across
our states, everywhere in the country.
So only about 15% actually come to the big medical center or the big academic
medical centers. So what does that mean?
Most of those community settings don't have clinical trials there because
they're not research centers, right?
And so that's a really big structural barrier for people to be able to participate
in clinical trials, in cancer clinical trials or any kind of clinical research
or cancer research.
So another kind of parallel to that is
as new advances in cancer treatments come out, they
start to be practiced at the academic medical centers, and then
eventually get disseminated out and into other
community settings, but sometimes they don't even get out because smaller hospitals
don't have the infrastructure or the resources to do some of those specialized and
advanced treatments. So that's another sort of gap that
patients who live farther from those more big urban
centers generally have. So those
two barriers
to care and cancer burden are two of the
things that the Markey Cancer Network
set out to address. It was created 20 years ago in 2006.
And I forgot to say, when I was talking about Kentucky, the context, we have the
number one highest cancer incidence and the number one highest cancer mortality in
the whole country,
our state. And then also,
most of that is actually driven by Appalachia.
I mean, if you look at the rates in Appalachia, they're even higher.
And there's a lot of cancers that were either in the top five or pretty high,
lung cancer and colorectal being key ones.
And rates are higher in rural areas
and in Appalachian areas, so it's really important for us to
help people be able to get to the care that they need to get the highest quality
care without having to drive three or four hours to Lexington, to Markey Cancer
Center to get
good treatment. So the vision that they set out 20 years ago
was, instead of working on getting people to come
to usLet's work on increasing the quality of the
care that's out in the community. So they started with a capacity building
approach and partnership approach, and it's grown from there.
So we now have 20 independently operated community hospitals.
These are not other locations of UK Healthcare.
These are separate, independent hospitals.
Some systems have that. They have locations all over their state.
That's not what this is. These are separate hospitals, and they pay to be
part of the network. So the goal is to have
increased access to higher quality cancer care close to home, and
higher access to cancer research close to home through a collaboration with
these community hospitals.
And if you look at where these hospitals serve, about
a third of the patients in the state live in the service areas of all of these
hospitals. So it has pretty good coverage of the state.
So they really built the network on
sort of the principle of mutual benefit,
because before,
Markey would go out in the community in different parts of the state and they would
say: "Why are you coming here? This is our area, it's our territory." So it was
seen as competition. So they said, "Let's turn competition into collaboration, and
how can we make mutually beneficial partnerships with all of these hospitals across
the state?"
So a key part of that was a sort of a hybrid cancer care model, where
the goal is to increase the capacity and
infrastructure of the care at the local community hospital so people can get their
care there. But like I said, they're not going to be able to do everything.
They're not going to be able to do CAR T-cell therapy, or they're not going to do
some really advanced robotic lung cancer surgeries and things like that.
So they coordinate with them to facilitate patients coming to
Markey for the specialized things, and then go back home to get their care back in
their community. So that's a really key thing, and so they can
trust Markey to do that.
That is a big value to those local community hospitals.
It helps they're able to use in their marketing, we're part of the Markey Cancer
Network, so it kind of gives them, they can kind of tag along on the prestige of
being associated with an NCI-designated cancer center,
and it improves patient experience, gives them better access to care, and then it
helps us work together on lowering barriers to screening, treatment, and clinical
research. And it really is built on relationships, like everything we do in
community outreach and engagement. This is our clinical outreach.
This is all built on relationships that they started 20 years ago.
And when I first came to Kentucky in 2020, the
medical director of the network set up
Zoom meetings with all of, because this was right after the shutdown, Zoom meetings
with all the CEOs of the hospitals.
And just as we were doing introductions before we even get into talking, every
single one of them said something to the effect of, "We love being
part of Markey Cancer Network. It is so valuable to us.
We get so much out of being part of this network, and
we really
benefit from this partnership, and we're so invested in it." So
I was just blown away
by that, and it's just really impressive, the really trusted relationships
they've built. So there's kind of four things that,
I would say maybe three that primarily bring value to the centers and
why they want to be part of it, and then the fourth one is research, which is sort
of a mutual thing. So one is a quality assurance program.
So the goal is so that every one of the network
hospitals can achieve and maintain Commission on Cancer or CoC
accreditation. And they're sort of high bar standards of high
quality cancer care that they have to meet.
So we have quality coordinators that meet directly with teams on a
regular basis, go through their activities, their reports,
give them templates, give them quality improvement feedback, and they also have
workshops and lunch and learn things.
And we currently have now 18 out of our 20 hospitals are
accredited, and two working towards accreditation.
And they're able to show that joining the network does in fact increase
quality care, because they looked at some data.
The dark blue bar is three years before hospitals joined the network, and
the lighter blue bar is three years after joining the network.
And this is three of the four quality
measures that they looked at for CoC, they had significant increases in those
quality measures. So it did tangibly increase the quality of care at
those hospitals. And there's some additional things I won't go into, but they have
some navigation ambassadors and clinical trial referral ambassadors, which
is training staff and nurses and staff at each
local hospital to promote
referring patients to Markey for clinical trials.
There's other ways, other things we do, and I'll talk about in a second.
But, and they also have a local chapter of AONN, Kentucky Oncology
Navigation Network, that we coordinate for the state.
A really key sort of complement to that quality
program is in the education program.
This is both annual in-person events, like an annual conference, and other
symposia, and also many virtual events during the year where
all of the staff, clinical staff, and non-clinical staff from the different sites
can
have skill building. So it's all about building infrastructure, and capacity, and
skills. And they get feedback on what they want to learn, and
the future topics are guided by that.
But there's tremendous reach over this five-year period here.
They had over almost 5,000 CE credits that they gave out for all these
various learning activities.
The third component is the part I was talking about, the hybrid care model.
How do they do that? They have five nurse liaisons
that personally facilitate every referral in
for the specialized care or special treatment that they need,
and as well as for clinical trials.
So they not only assist the patients with barriers to care and logistics,
but they also do all the care coordination, getting records sent over and stuff
like that. And then facilitate when they're done with the part that they need at
Markey, facilitate them getting back home, and all the information getting back to
the clinician there. And you can see just the increase of
referrals that we've had over the past few years.
I think last year was almost 1,000.Those are
the three things I think that really bring the big value to the
partner hospitals.
And then the fourth area that we work together on is research capacity building,
because one of the COC standards actually is participating in research as an
institution. So six of the sites
actually have their own research infrastructure they were able to build up so
they can conduct clinical trials.
They are actual therapeutic trials they can conduct on-site at those hospitals.
And, they have gone through a really rigorous vetting and onboarding and
training process to be part of these research sites in the network,
and our staff work very closely with them on that.
And then the other sites are not even aspiring to have that
extent of research infrastructure.
They may be smaller hospitals, but they also want to be involved in research
opportunities, so we've devised a way that they can participate in other
types of studies, not the therapeutic trials, but other observational and
non-therapeutic interventions, where they can be part of the research
study, but not be officially engaged in research.
That means our Markey staff are the ones who consent and
enroll the patients and do the intervention procedures with them,
if it's an intervention.
But they work very closely together on that.
They do additional training and networking and professional development topics
as well throughout the year for them.
And this is just a sampling of that.
Since 2016, we've had over 1,400 accruals
that have been enrolled at those sites.
So when they enroll, if they're the six
fully engaged research sites, when they enroll patients, they're their own
accruals. They're not Markey accruals. It's accruals at that hospital.
So they don't go in our data table for CCSG, for example, as accruals.
Interesting.
They're local accruals. So those essentially have been patients who
otherwise would not have had access to research, who were able to participate in
research studies. And then the ones who we do the hybrid
model, where
our staff consent them, they do count on our data table as enrollees,
but they work together. But this is just a couple of last few
years, and it's partial data for 2025.
Sorry, but it just gives you-- To show there's a mixture of investigator-initiated
trials as well as the national NCTN trials as
well.
And here's a breakdown of the types of studies.
So almost two-thirds are treatment interventions, about 30%
diagnostic observational studies, and then the others are other types
of non-therapeutic interventions, health services, primarily
interventions.
So that's kind of what the network does and how we both-- So we
facilitate research happening at the sites and in partnership with Markey and
also
referrals to clinical trials that are only at Markey, that aren't available
at those sites as well.
So the other piece I'm going to talk about is research advocacy program, and that's
something we recently started in 2021, and this is something that
we wanted to have-- Both of these things are about
building infrastructure, talking about sustainability.
In order to sustain something, you have to have infrastructure that can
sustain. So we've been successful with that with the network,
so I wanted to build some new infrastructure to have a consistent
and replicable system and process for us to be
able to support projects involving
patient advocates in their research. So again, these are not research participants.
These are partners in the research.
So we wanted to be able to facilitate them being directly involved as research team
partners, so the patient perspectives and experience can be infused throughout the
research studies from the beginning, from conception through dissemination.
Who are our advocates? We include cancer survivors, and they have to
have been at least one year out of treatment, not during treatment, because they
need to be focusing on themselves at that time.
And then caregivers of former patients, again, they also have to be at
least one year out of that treatment experience or passing away.
And then community organizations, a variety of types.
Some are cancer-focused, and there are other community organizations, depending on
the topic. So for each project, we bring together
a mixture of survivors, caregivers, and
organizations that is tailored to the project.
But always looking for diverse backgrounds and experiences, different
parts of the state,
and some are focused on specific cancer sites, for example.
So we kind of customize it to the project.
So we orient the investigators that if they want to be part of this
program, they need to understand that their advocates that are part of the
project are full partners on their project.
They are going to contribute their perspectives and opinions.
We
then facilitate the meetings so that we make sure that's done in a way that
can make people feel comfortable in participating.
And then they can give feedback on very specific parts of the study.
We structure the meeting so that we have very specific things that they can
give feedback on. And then also dissemination as well,
getting results prepared to share back out to the community, looking at
dissemination products, giving feedback on those, and also getting things back
out in the community.
This is just some highlights of the numbers since we started.
We've supported 15 proposals being submitted, about half
and half internal, external. That's how many advocates were proposed to be on
the projects. And the bottom is the type.
What was in FY24, I think that's the current year.
FY26. Currently, at this moment, are supporting
three externally funded projects and six internal.
So about 55, 54 advocates that are actively
involved in projects right now. So it's a lot.
We have a full-time manager who manages the program and facilitates all the
communications with the advocates.
We have a training, an onboarding training,
and then
they also get oriented to each specific project.
We're going to be starting up very soon,
in addition to these sort of... patient advocate committees that are attached to a
project, we're going to be starting a sort of one-time consultation
option, where it may be a clinical trial that's already
in process, and they're just having trouble recruiting, and they don't know what's
going on, or it's a team that's just kind of starting to develop an idea, and
they're not sure which direction they want to go yet.
So we can bring together a group of advocates to give feedback
during a focus session with an investigator.
So that's another thing we're going to be doing.
So we do pay, of course, the advocates for their time, $50
per hour. And so the research
project is responsible for covering their payments.
And if they come into in-person meetings, they have to pay for
their mileage and other travel expenses if they stay overnight.
So I'm going to give just two examples of projects that have worked with us, with
advocates. One is a basic scientist, Dr.
Zhu, and he had a pilot, one of our community-based research pilots with our
Community Impact office. And his focus was on how does obesity
contribute to the high breast cancer mortality rates in Appalachia.
And he was specifically looking for linking obesity, dense
breasts, and breast cancer survival.
And this protein thing, I can't tell you.
This protein and collagen and stuff, like if women had that, do they have high risk
of dying from breast cancer? And you can see on the right, the advocates came
in to tour the lab and kind of see the research that they're doing, looking in the
microscope at the things that they're looking at.
They really enjoyed that. And just an example of some of the
things that they contributed in the discussion was asking, "Okay, so you're
looking at this stuff in the cells.
What is this going to mean for breast cancer patients?
When you have your findings, where's this going to go?
What is that going to mean for us? And how will it affect what we do for prevention
and screening for breast cancer? Could it change things?" And it
really helped him think through the future direction of his research.
We've seen that a lot with basic scientists.
Sometimes
it's hard for them to think outside the scope of their
one project and what is the eventual public health impact going to be of their
research. So I think it's really helpful for them to both learn
how to communicate about their science to non-scientists and other people who just
aren't experts in that field, but also to really articulate the public health
impact of their research. Another one is our PRIMAL study
that was looking at another way that we can help increase access
to the most advanced lung cancer treatments for patients across the state.
And this is through our, we have a molecular tumor board, a virtual molecular tumor
board, where
currently any hospital who wants to can submit a case, an anonymized patient case,
say, "Here's their genomic testing, their molecular testing,"
and then the molecular tumor board
reviews it and gives them the recommendations based on this and the current
guidelines. Here are the treatment options, kind of the precision medicine
treatment options that you have for the patient.
So their study was facilitating
that biomarker testing process and in bringing assistance
in getting those cases submitted and things through the
tumor board process. And they have quality of life surveys, and it actually
informed a new biomarker testing policy in the state to require
insurance companies to
cover that.
And one of the kind of key questions, sort of unexpected questions that came
out of this, because this is about treating advanced lung cancer treatments, and a
lot of them are patients who are former smokers or current
smokers. But one of the advocates said, "Well, what about
with non-smokers? Are you looking at-- what are the variants that you see,"
because they learned that word. "What are the variants you see for non-smokers?
Is there a difference with people who smoke and people who don't smoke?
Because I'm a young cancer..." Not me.
The advocate said, "I'm a
young lung cancer survivor, and I never smoked.
And then we got my house tested for radon.
We got the school tested for radon where I went to school, and they found it had
high radon," and helped them get it
remediated. But anyway, "So what about us?
We're 20% of lung cancer cases now." So she's like, "That's a really good
question." So that led to them doing some new data analysis and a new paper on
analyzing the people who are smokers
versus non-smokers and the variants and the outcomes of those patients.
So those are two examples, and I want to end with this quote from one of the basic
scientists that we've worked with.
I'll just let you kind of read it for a second, but
I think it touched on a few important points.
"We think we have these great research ideas, but if the community doesn't trust
us, we'll get nowhere. It won't go anywhere.
We get caught up sometimes in the details of our research, and forget the bigger
picture and what it means to the community, and having bi-directional interaction
helps keep us honest and allows us the opportunity to build trust with our
community." So thank you.
I have no idea how long that was.
That's perfect. Thanks. So you can see the breadth of what
COE is expected to do. So that was really incredible to
see the community being embedded across the research, the
different types of research. So, we're going to ask Dr.
Lorna McNeill, who is Professor and Chair of Health Disparities Research
and Associate Director of COE from MD Anderson,
to bring us home and to give you the full perspective on how
COE can pivot, because look at all we are expected to do.
It's insane.
Yes.
Get them.
Thank you, Dr. Rhodes.
So thank you all for hanging in
there with us. So I'm going to pivot a little bit to
sustainability. And so you've been hearing a lot of great work
that all of us in our cancer centers do to engage our
communities to try to have lasting impact.
But a major criticism or even requirement of is like, "Okay, you've done
all this stuff, then how do you maintain it?
How do you make sure that it doesn't go away?" So
normally we focus on funding when we think about that, but one of the things I'm
going to focus on is... actual process of engaging communities
as sustainability.
So I don't have any financial relationships to disclose.
I wish I did, actually.
So,
one of my thesis is that community engagement is very
powerful, as you can see,
and it increases the participation in, and the relevance, and the
impact of our cancer research. But what is
community engagement? I'm going to circle us back, I think, to Dr.
Rhoads' initial presentation,
to kind of tie it all together. So it's the process that we use
to work collaboratively with and through groups of people,
and that we normally think of community engagement as looking at a
geographic proximity, urban versus rural, particular
neighborhoods, special interest groups, or people in
similar situations. We engage them to address
issues that affecting this particular population and these particular groups of
people. This is our old school CDC definition.
And the goals of engaging communities are to build trust,
to provide enlist new resources and allies, to
increase better communication, you've heard some of the presentations already talk
about that, and overall to improve health outcomes,
and that these projects that we work on together can evolve into these
lasting collaborations.
And community engagement is not new.
We've been doing it for many, many years, and many different cultures call it
various different things, but it's the process of knowing and
understanding and helping by literally talking to people.
And I know that it's, like I said, it's not novel, but it feels novel
these days that the way that you work, and build,
and create impact is to actually get out of our offices, go into
communities, and talk to people and understand what they are experiencing and how
science can actually help improve their lives and make a difference.
So there's a basis for this, the science of community
engagement. And these are just some of the theories and frameworks that have been
developed over many, many years, starting with social determinants, well, not
starting with, one of the social determinants of health in the 1990s.
And one of the things that that told us or helped us understand, that there are
social and economic and environmental conditions that
are at play for producing the health conditions that we see
in communities and populations, not entirely to people's fault.
It is a situation that is embedded within the neighborhoods in
which people live. There are social ecological models that basically
tell us that it's important to look at
people and conditions and populations at multiple levels of influence.
So we focus a lot on the individual and what they do or don't do.
You smoke or you don't smoke, you exercise or you don't.
But really, we need to look at these multiple levels.
There's the individual level, but what is involved in the community?
What resources are available in the community?
What is available from a systematic perspective and policies?
All of these things shape our health, even more
so than our decision to smoke or not smoke.
There's social capital theory, which really focuses on relationships and
networks. I was trained in community-based participatory research
back in the '90s,
and that is where we really started to engage communities as partners,
and really suggesting that we don't just want to do things to people, but we want
to do things, and improve health with people.
And then a new one is collective impact framework, and that is where
everybody is working together on the same goal.
We might have competing interests, but when we come together, we're all working on
this shared common goal. And I think many of us use most of
these frameworks in a lot of the work that we do.
So there's a big difference about doing research that's on
populations and communities, and I would argue that's a lot of what we used to do,
calling our participants subjects.
We really have moved away from that and moved into language of
participants,
even in populations and communities to with populations.
And I think going in that direction of doing things with, doing things in
partnership, is a direction that we really want all of our science to
go, and you've heard reasons today for why that's so impactful to do that.
And so when we think about community, though, I think that
many, not us in this room, but many other people think
of community as those people over there. Them.
They don't think of community as me, as us.
We are all the community. I am the community. You are the community.
Because community can be as narrow as you want it to be or as very broad as you
want it to be. Community is patients, and all of us are going to be
patients one day. We're all going to get something if we don't have anything.
If you're 100% healthy now, great, enjoy it.
But something is coming down the horizon.
But we're all a patient community, where families are communities, our
nonprofit organizations, cultural group, faith-based organizations, and
generally the public. And so what I want to sort of stress is that
we have to really understand that the community is each one of us.
And when we think about science and the research that we do, we would want to
know that researchers are engaging with whatever community that they
are working with or studying. Right? I have not had cancer.
Hopefully never, but I am not a cancer survivor.
I don't know the experience of cancer survivors.
But when I engage with that community, I think that the community would
like to know that I've been engaging with that population when I want to design
research studies. Been a long time since I've been an adolescent and
a youth. When you do work with kids and youth, you need to engage
them, talk to them, understand what they are experiencing so that you know that the
research that you're doing is relevant to them.
If you see yourself as not part of something, but in recognizing you need the
help of that community to make an impact, you won't see yourself as different, and
you won't look at them as those people.
And so there's a continuum of partnership and collaboration from
outreach all the way to shared leadership.
And I would argue all of these are good.
None of them are bad, because sometimes some communities that you work with,
outreach is good. They're good with that.
And then othersThey're like, "No, we want to be more involved, that we are
tired of people coming in and out. We want to have more of a shared leadership
model." But I do a lot of work with churches and faith-based communities, and
not all of them want shared leadership.
They have day jobs which is saving souls, and they're not
necessarily wanting to engage in that kind of way.
So outreach and consultation is sometimes fine, depending on what
you're seeking to do. But the goal is to be in
partnership and have some kind of collaboration model.
And when we do that, these are principles of community engagement.
What we're building is trust and respect that the work that we're
doing is inclusive of all of us, all of the minds, all of the thought
processes, all of the experiences.
We're enhancing collaboration, empowerment.
Transparency is one of my favorite ones, because the minute you work with
communities, they will let you know that.
Yeah.
They were-
That's good stuff
... questioning whether or not everything you're doing is on the up and up, and
what are you necessarily hiding and what are you not sharing?
They don't necessarily say it in those ways, but what you're getting at
is, it's important for me to be authentic and there's accountability there.
And ultimately, with mutual benefit for everyone.
So if sustainability is the goal, then I
argue that community engagement is the engine.
So what do we mean by sustainability?
So sustainability is the ability of programs and partnerships impact
to endure and remain relevant over time.
That something that you think that you're building in the 2000s or might still be
there in 2026, provided that people want these things to
continue. And so our core components of that sustainability
are relationships and trust. It is local
capacity and leadership of everyone that's involved, that
they feel like there is some stake in it for everyone
that's there. It does require institutional support as well as
shared governance and resource
flows that persist. So we do need funding.
But I want to know, sustainability is not just funding.
You can have things that persist that without funding, and you can have
things that have funding that don't persist.
So, at the end of the day, it's important, but it's not
necessarily the only element. And why does sustainability matter?
It's because we want things that we do to last.
We want them to have a long-term impact over many, many years.
And that's not measured in every grant cycle.
You can't measure sustainability by whether or not a grant is there.
It's really measured over many, many years.
And communities do remember when programs disappear.
"Oh, we used to have this," or, "This used to be there, and now it's not
here anymore." And whenever we want to come and talk about something new,
there is a thought, "Is this going to stay?" And whether or not I want to engage
in something that doesn't last. I was in another session with persistent
poverty communities, and there was a researcher, Dr.
David Wetter, he's doing things with FQHCs.
And one of the things that FQHC says, "If this does not last beyond the grant
period, we do not want to implement it within our clinic system." So think about
that ahead of time. I think funders increasingly expect lasting
impact. So everybody knows now we have a new section.
We have to talk about sustainability.
Lots of pressure to figure out how we're going to do that.
But without that sustainability, impact seems, might feel
episodic and temporary. So I think that community
engagement is actually the secret sauce.
It is the secret sauce to sustainability.
And so how does engagement drive sustainability?
Well, engagement builds trust, and trust builds that continued
participation. And that continued participation can create
shared ownership so that programs just don't end when the funding
ends, but people and communities and groups, whatever community, as you
define it, that you're working with, starts to feel like this program is
theirs. It's something that they have a vested interest and want to see it
continue. And that shared ownership is one of the
ways in which it can lead to sustainability.
But I didn't want to not talk about funding, because funding is a mechanism of
sustainability. And more increasingly, as I mentioned, community
engagement matters to our funders.
And so sustainable community engagement does require some diverse
funding streams. So, pharma, our industry partners, they
are great partners in this space. And I
think, maybe back in the day, maybe not so much, but today, I
think we're finding shared commonality and shared goals, where they want to do
things that are sustainable and that last as well.
There's lots of philanthropic donors who are interested in this space and
foundations. They can also help us from a funding perspective,
maintain sustainability. And yes, all of our cancer centers need to
be doing things, that institutional investments, building that
infrastructure. And that's one of the things that COE has definitely done is
building infrastructure that the cancer center is required to
do, which is one of the things that we can demonstrate that we will still be
here, time and time again, even when our funding ends.
Not every single thing, but many things should remain.
And funders are increasingly valuing
sustainability. They are valuing that we have these authentic partnerships.
You couldn't get money to just give you money to build
relationships, because relationships takes time. No, no, no.
We need to increase colorectal screening rates.
We need to increase physical activity.
We don't want to fund you to build these relationships.
But I think more and more, they're recognizing that value of authentic
partnerships. And if you think about COVID, COVID was one of those times
where we were able to harness community engagement
in order to create awareness... about COVID and try to
increase vaccination among populations.
And so this demonstrated trust, and potential for long-term impact
is becoming very valuable to funders.
And so I think the community engagement strengthens the credibility, relevance,
and funder confidence that makes sustainability
investable, something they want to invest in.
So I recently received funding from Bristol Myers Squibb Foundation to focus on
breast cancer disparities, and one of the things they invested in us
doing was building this coalition of organizations within the greater
Houston area to work together to decrease the Black-White
disparity of breast cancer and have it come down over the next 10 years.
So I've got initial five years of funding to meet and work
together and build trust and so my point is, I think that this
is becoming an investable area. So I was going to give two examples,
one of which I won't go into a lot because Dr.
Hull already talked about a program of her research advocacy program.
It's similar to the community scientist program, that we have at MD
Anderson.
And it's similar, we train community members who provide feedback to
researchers. This is more of a rapid feedback, one-time, sort of
one-on-one, not one-on-one, but engagement that can be one time or it can be many
times. But the main thing is that we're trying to get research to engage with our
community scientists before, when you have an idea, before
your research starts, as well as after. But normally they come after.
"We're not accruing to our study. Can you help us?
What do we need to do?" "Oh, people are having a hard time figuring out our
informed consent document. Can you help us fix it?" So can we stop doing that
after, and can we bring these issues and things up ahead of time?
So a diverse group of community scientists have been trained, and they
share their lived experiences, and these are the areas in Texas where we have
them. So really, they pretty much span the state minus the central area.
And we recently published an evaluation of that.
So over 160 community scientists have been trained, and they've given feedback
now over 200 times to researchers.
So one of the things that we did is we asked community scientists, how do they
think that they are contributing to research, and do they think that this is
a worthwhile effort? And so 100% said they felt that their
feedback was valued, and they feel like it's worth their time,
and that the feedback that they provided improved their research
project. And their top four contributions is that they feel like
they helped researchers increase their understanding of the community, their
sensitivity to the community, and provided feedback.
When we continue to evaluate this year after year, we get these same
answers and the same feedback. What that tells us is this idea of
coming and presenting to community scientists, they feel is
valuable, and therefore, it will continue.
It will continue as long as we reach out to them and ask them to provide impact.
It's a sustainability model in that they will continue to show up and provide
that feedback. So our job is to make sure we incorporate the suggestions that they
have, and if they do, they feel like they're making a difference in the science
that we are doing within our cancer center, and so really proud of that.
Another sustainability model is one of the initiatives
that we have at MD Anderson. It's called Be Well initiative.
It's a place-based initiative where we partner with
communities to implement evidence-based actions that will help
improve outcomes in that community. And guess what?
We don't ask for anything back. We don't ask them to participate on a research
study. We don't ask them to recruit for anything.
We don't ask anything. This is communities that
have health needs. We have evidence-based programs, screening, all
kinds of things that will benefit.
And we've identified funding from various philanthropic organizations to
say, "This is a community that we need to be investing in," and then we
do. So this is not a real map of this community. It's called Acres Homes.
But it shows you some of the investable things that have been done there, the
infrastructure that has been built from a focus on parks and rec.
You want a sunscreen, you want sun shades?
We will help provide those sun shades.
Education and youth program, community gardens, you name it.
The main part of this is that it involves lots of different
sectors within this community. So not just that neighborhood, the school system,
the mayor's office. It involves community-based
organizations. Everybody comes together to design these
programs together. So over time, in this particular
neighborhood, 21 million pounds of healthy food has been distributed, 82 sun
shades have been created,
and it has impacted about 676,000
community members across all of the Be Well communities, and there's four.
But sustainability is built in this model.
So it starts with a community assessment, but together with community partners,
the planning and the implementation, the sustainability, is all done at the
same time in concert. So the succession
is the coalition and the partnerships.
The community selects a community-based organization to lead this
effort after two to three years. So MD Anderson is no longer leading it
and/or coordinating the meetings.
One of the community organizations is now leading that.
The communication strategies come from what we are communicating from the cancer
center to identifying a community partner that does communication, and
then we've turned those things over to them, and they start to distribute the
communications in the community, and likewise, policy and
infrastructure. Around 90% of the implemented programs have been sustained
because the city government has come on board to help fund these initiatives.
So another sustainability model.
So in conclusion, if we want sustainability, we must
design for relationships and not just results.
Measure success, in my view, by what remains after
the funding ends. Funding may go away, but what's still there?
What is built that is really long-lasting?
And I would argue lots of relationships are.
And treat community engagement as a core scientific infrastructure that is
needed to fuel everything that we want to do from an impact perspective. Thank you.
Oh, acknowledge everybody and then me.
Okay, are your minds blown?
Because we started with the challenges to getting this work done, right?
And you see each of these three COE leaders have just blown past
those challenges
and kept it moving. So really want to appreciate you for that.
I want to just ask if anybody has any questions or
comments or thoughts that they want to share.
There are two mics on both sides of the room.
Well, I'll start. Hi, my name's Nicole Hansen,
a recent breast cancer survivor.
Being a breast cancer survivor has obviously been really
eye-opening for me,
but particularly in the area of COE and the
importance of patient navigators.
For me, specifically,
I'm a working mom of three, so I worked through my whole treatment
at Massey,
and I'm now cancer-free. Yay.
And my husband also
works, and
we don't have family nearby, so we ended up
having
all of our friends do a sign-up sheet of who was going to drive me to chemo
every week
for six months,
because every time you sit in the chemo chair, you
can't drive.
And
I was lucky enough to have a support system.
But every time I got in that car with one of my friends,
all I could think about was all the people who don't have that support system.
And every time I ask
a researcher about this, because it's the same for getting people to clinical
trials, getting them to treatment in general,
what ideas do you have, or what do you think are
possibilities for creating sustainable
options to bridge those gaps?
I'll open that for any of you.
Yeah, I'll get started. So, I want to introduce Elena
Nieves, who's here. And Elena is sort of our key
patient navigator. And the work that Elena does is
she's likely to go to your home to pick you up if she needs to.
But it's really important work, and that's not
normally funded, that kind of work.
But we've been able to secure donors' money that has
really made a difference. So,
through the Lazarex Cancer Foundation, which just recently folded
because of the whole climate,
we were able to navigate patients all the way
through, identifying them from the community into clinical trials.
So, just last year,
under the leadership of Carolina and
Elena, both sitting here, we were able to identify 149 people
at the community level that needed follow-up, and then ended up
getting in through our system.
So, sometimes you have to go outside the box, kind of blow up the
box a little bit, to get that kind of service.
Right now, through a donor, we're able to provide
some funding.
We funded funerals.
We have funded
street fruit vendors who couldn't work because they were getting chemo
and couldn't be on the corner
selling their fruits. We have funded rent money
for families.
But that has to come through the philanthropy that is done through the
cancer center. And really key is this cancer center
director,
and their involvement, and their
efforts in philanthropy, because those kinds of things that you
mentioned are incredibly needed, but usually are not part of
the research projects or those that are funded to do
that.
And I was going to say similarly, we had funding from Lazarex.
God bless Lazarex-
We did
... to do the same thing. And
so, for some people, it's transportation, it's parking,
it's food. It is any
out-of-pocket costs that are associated with your cancer
treatment, which can be expensive.
It was reimbursing people for those out-of-pocket costs.
And so similarly, through philanthropy,
those things are available. But really, at the end of the
day, it's us to constantly challenge our cancer centers that this is a
responsibility. This is part of your COE responsibility that should not necessarily
be claim-friendly. And not everybody needs it.
But for those that do, that it's available.
And so, some ways, it's doing a better job of identifying the
needs of all of our patient populations and trying to identify ways to meet those.
But I'm glad that you were able to get that.
Oh, and last thing I would say, Lyft is also a really great community
partner. They want to be in this space with us to be able to provide
transportation. And so I recently was doing some work with them.
And anyway, that's another group of
organization to reach out to.
Okay.
We have a similar program, not under our office, but our cancer does.
And we have a research study where we're working on a patient
app to help the navigators and social workers.
And also so the patient can
have access to information while they're at home and look for resources and
get personalized recommendations on services that can help them.
And I just want to highlight that a lot of the examples that were just given are
about community supporting community.
Even Nicole, even your example.
I think we had a question on this side, and then we'll go to this side, and then
we'll come back
I thank you so much, first of all, for the great presentations.
My name is Peter Theodorowski. My own research is about
patient and community engagement.
How can we involve members of the public, the lived experience of the cancers, the
co-researchers, especially in research?
So when you talk about the research advocacy program and the community scientists
program, what I'm really interested about, how do you train them
actually to provide that perspective into the
research? How do you support them through that process in terms of the induction
and development? And especially, how can you ensure and
help them to reflect, to keep their perspectives as the lay members of the
public, not to start to become more of the researchers?
How to keep that balance in it.
And please, when you respond to that, let us know if you have anything publicly
available that other institutions can...
Content that we can pull down and train people.
And I don't have it on our website, but definitely if you email me,
then we have the PowerPoint slides for our
training. So anyway, our community scientists go through a four-hour training,
with one aspect is Research 101. So what
they have some hesitancy is not understanding some scientific
concepts, and so we remove that, not remove, but
provide them some basics of what some scientific concepts are and so forth.
At the same time, though, our researchers are required to speak in plain language
when they are meeting with them. So everybody's working towards getting in the
middle in terms of conversation. But another module of that
is the power of their lived experiences, and
that is what the researchers are coming for.
So you don't need to try to be scientists. That's not what they are looking for.
They're actually looking for, how does this play in real life?
What are people really dealing with?
And so we talk more about your lived experience and how powerful that
is and lean into that all the time. In case you might think, "Oh, they
want to hear it, say it anyway." Right?
And then we do a lot of role plays in
the training, where you're going to create, "This
recruitment material, but what would you suggest?
This informed consent document, what would you say? Oh, they're not recruiting.
How would you..." And so they gain that experience of providing
feedback, so they gain confidence in what they're saying and how
valuable that is. And so now, you can't tell our community
scientists anything. When a researcher comes before them, watch out,
researcher. Because you're going to hear all of the things that they have
been working over many, many times in order to harness that voice.
So they are very, very confident when they meet with researchers.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't have anything to add.
We have similar things, and I think a lot of it's about
training the researcher as well. And we usually like to have in one of the
first
times they meet or first in person, is to have them
identify the researcher and the patient and the
caregiver. What do I contribute to the table?
What I want to learn from each of the others, and then what do I contribute as
well? And so it helps them see. We just kind of emphasize that
everyone is here as an expert in something.
You're an expert in your experience, and so to kind of
overcome, it's more of a confidence thing of like, "I don't know stuff.
I'm not the scientist. I don't know all those things." So we try to
just explain that you don't need to know that.
We're asking you to come because you know these other things
that the researchers need to learn from you.
And so that helps also for the researchers to kind of get oriented
to understand that I'm not supposed to just come here as the expert, tell everybody
how things are. Yeah, so.
If I could just add to that, we also have a community scientist
program, which I'll talk about at a presentation tomorrow.
But one thing in addition to what these ladies have been mentioning is that
our program is a 10 weeks program, and the community
scientists get paid for being in the program.
And in addition to that, we provide them with a
$1,000 to develop a program that they develop
with our community researchers and with
the staff. Carolina and Eduardo helped lead that from the
USC side, and they are very actively
engaged in really understanding.
It doesn't have to be a pure research project. It could be an advocacy project.
It could be... And so they get first-hand experience on working with
the researchers and on developing this as well.
Perfect. Thank you so much.
And please come up and engage our speakers at the end because
they may, as I said, these tools already exist, so you don't need to
recreate the wheel.
Sharon Rivera-Sanchez from Richmond, Virginia.
I am a cancer survivor, thriver, patient advocate,
and I would just like to comment on Nicole.
Transportation was built in our seed grant from
Massey. So you can build that in. I don't know about
now, but it definitely was there. I would agree with
everything the panel say. You must think out the box, and as
a cancer survivor, you can create anything.
Anything is possible.
All right, we're going to take one last question.
I think we're at the end of our session.
Hi, I'm Heather Hurwitz from Cleveland Clinic and the Case Comprehensive
Cancer Center, and your work is very inspiring,
where some things resonate with pieces that we're trying to do
also.
And I'm just curious, as you build more and do some
of these innovative programs and
advocate for community engagement more, are there things that
you're doing to educate your peers and your leadership and
maybe your legal team or your marketing team that really kind of
resonate, so that they are on board with how important this is, too?
Do you have any tips for those pieces of it?
That's a great question.
Sure.
Yes.
All of the above.No, I don't.
It's a struggle. It's a challenge. I don't know about potential.
Yes, we constantly have to do that.
I'm fortunate, and again, the reason why I came to Kentucky is because our
director is very committed to community outreach and engagement, and
UK and the marque has a really long history of doing it.
So I came somewhere where I knew it would be supported.
But
other leadership as well, we have to constantly remind, "This is
the way we do things. This is how you incorporate perspectives," things like
that. But
I don't know if you want to add.
Sure. I think there, again,
you really have to see who your cancer center director is and what
difference does that make, because I know ours currently is Karen Lerman,
who is stepping down, and we're so sad about that.
But she has secured a model by which we work directly with
marketing and the Keck School of Medicine,
as well as with social media. So she
insists that constantly we are
giving her information that is vetted
within the cancer center, and that then is put out publicly
through the entire Keck School of Medicine, influencing 27
departments. And the cancer center becomes
the premier place to provide those
examples to the rest. And so that, I think,
really depends on who's at the helm and who is
really making that difference overall.
I guess a tip is just to
always
kind of highlight the successes and the examples of
partnerships and the great things that come out of them, and how,
"We want to do on this grant, we need to pull some partners together,"
to always remind them, just in case.
We can't just call people up that we don't know.
We have to build this relationship over time and just always be sharing the
process as well as the outcomes. They want to hear
the end numbers, but always kind of communicate, this is all the work
that goes into it as well.
So yeah.
All right. With that, I want to thank each of our speakers,
Lourdes, Pamela, and Lorna,
for doing incredible work despite the barriers that
are being put in front of us
on a structural level.
I want to just close out by
sharing with you that when I trained as a community organizer
in medical school, I went to the Saturday School for Community Leaders
at the Center for Third World Organizing in Oakland, California.
And at the end of the training, we all got a T-shirt, and it said, "We will either
find a way or make one."
And I just want to say that COE and the COE leaders you see here on the
stage, and many of the COE leaders that you interact with around the country,
are finding a way or making one.
Yeah.
So thank you so much for being here.
And thank you, Kim.
Great session, Kim.